welcome to this video a new part of
endgame strategy yeah this is um an end
game and game position that is from a
game yah Malinsky playing wild against
Kasparov playing black it is a mix
pieces endgame both sides have a rook
and minor piece we have Bishop on the
white side against Knight on the black
side yeah how to assess this position
let's have a look there are various
factors of course that determine such an
evaluation the first thing that always
needs to be considered is the pawn
structure black has a very sound
structure he has got one pawn island and
a second corn island so to pawn islands
total while White has one island two
islands isolated pawns here and then
he's got this central formation which
you can count as one or two depending on
your taste
probably one is the the technically
right definition but it is sort of yeah
it is separated this island c4 and d5
and a 1 unit if you want and III and
therefore the second so we actually are
talking about a number of palm
weaknesses that White has the most
serious once a to c43 h2 is very
difficult to get it but he has a number
of weaknesses while black has basically
no own weakness let's consider the minor
pieces the knight is simply the better
piece in the structure it is a closed
structure
yeah there's no file assisters
completely open it is a closed structure
that that the famous slow maneuvering in
a way the knight also has got some
favorable posts and we see later in the
game what the most favorable post is the
bishop on the other hand here it has no
decent scope
it's looking mostly at its own pawn
which makes it really a bad Bishop also
in a theoretical sense that those pawns
are on light squares while we have a
light squared bishop and furthermore it
cannot really be activated on some great
great square its huge difference that is
a light squared bishop not dark squared
bishop for example if we would have a
dark squared Bishop on e5 you know then
this is another story the bishop on fer
ever is really bad another interesting
factor is that lots of the play is going
to happen on the Queen side and the
black King is on the Queen side so it is
probably a little bit quicker enjoining
the action there the White King on g1
will take some moves to to get to the
Queen side what about the protected
passed pawn on d5 this d5 pawn here is
this an advantage for white hmm those
protected passed pawns are very often
um evaluated very highly by computers
and quite often justifiably so but this
is not one of those positions and the
reason is that this pawn is not going
anywhere
it cannot be advanced and this means
that it is not an important asset in
fact the black setup that is coming up
on the board now pretty much shows that
this pawn is not a strength at all the
question is it is black to move here how
to proceed now what is the best possible
set up for built for blacks pieces and
the most important moment actually is
coming right here you need to find the
best possible setup and of course
Kasparov shows the way he plays the move
loop d6y rook d6 yeah the rook is not a
great block ADA of a pawn but it is not
intending to stay there of course what
black has some now found is
the best possible setup for his pieces
and this best possible setup is rook
over to a four you want to go to a four
why them because this is the best
possible place for it because it acts as
a yeah it takes two things this pawn and
this pawn it attacks two targets and
this means this is the most efficient
way to place rook any other square on
the board it will only attack one target
I mean theoretically speaking like h3
but well if you're for example looking
at the move like that it will attack
this one target which can be easily
defended by the King on the other hand
on a form it attacks two targets where
the white rook is then pretty much
condemned to passive defense so Luke t6
is simply is simply the best the best
way to play wide stride rook a3
King b8 to cover that and now route b3
there was also the idea of rook b6 so
it's something that he couldn't avoid in
the long run
rook a six a three and now we come to
the next step how is black proceeding
from here of course you could play rook
a form but there is an even better way
to play and this is the second step in
the whole procedure black now played
nine three eight it means that some of
you probably have anticipated right at
the start of the whole thing because the
best possible place for the knight is
clearly d6 this ideal blockading square
in front of the protected passer which
serves ya is the dual purpose position
of the night it stops the part and it
attacks the weakness on c4 that's the
beauty of a blockading night it has a
dual function it has a defensive
function and then attacking and
attacking function attacking the c-4
weakness yeah white now tried to free
himself with e4 very understandable
decision I think this is clearly the
right the right way to proceed
it is weakening this a little bit but
you want to free your bishop and also
you want to reduce the pawn count and
try to trade down as much as possible
however we see that after 96 with the
temple Bishop d3 rook a form black has
managed his ideal formation as described
at the beginning of the of the video it
is this
attack against those weakness that is
now established rooks III to keep
everything together
King c7 King F - okay
and yeah how to proceed now this is now
very instructive Black has basically
gotten everything in that he could
manage yeah the the Lucas on the most
active square the night on the sixes
optimally placed and what now if we
check further possibilities we can
always distinguish between two things
black could try to improve pieces I mean
he has improved look and night very
nicely can you improve something else
the King difficult the King on c7 where
should it go especially in relation to
the Queen side weaknesses so we can't
really only make some headway with palm
breaks and in fact black here has a very
nice dynamic solution to the whole thing
the move b5 strong play back Kasparov it
is in a way a little bit illogical to
open up the position for the white
bishop but this is really not mattering
that much it's about very concrete
consideration here white has to take and
after that King to b6 and now we see the
idea this was simply a very dynamic
solution to the hole through the whole
problem with c4 coming
black manages to get back the b5 pawn
and in the process he has activated his
King even further to b6 possibly to c5
and he has isolated the d5 pawn so
there's a huge probability that black
will win both of those pawns both of
these pawns those pawns okay King III
there's really nothing that that white
can do him c4 has to retreat yeah and
now we see a tactical sequence because
peril has
correctly calculating calculated that
night XB v is just very strong right now
it has nothing else than capturing on a
form black captured on c3 years so we
have traded down to a minor his endgame
where white has this bishop attacked at
the moment bishop went to e8
there also was Bishop c2 at them it's a
very similar thing actually to Bishop e8
the next month is again important what
should black play now the most obvious
move of course is Knight takes d5 check
however this is not the best move let's
have a look if he takes on d5 the
problem is that why this all of a sudden
getting some activity witness king like
c3 and Bishop f4 black is of course
still better but it is not clear that it
is a win simply because White's King has
activated so much the starting position
it is much better to play the move that
Kasparov really went for in the game he
played King to c5 King up first this is
really better this way you prevent any
sort of activity coming from the white
side emmalin's key now tried T six and
now we see the big difference there is a
check on d5 yeah what should Y do now
he went to e-form yeah it is probably
the best chance of relatively speaking
but if he would have gone back somehow
like here then we can take and now we
see that those pieces are basically
blocking the White King so with this
precise order of moves we have prevented
any activation of white skin so always
make sure that you have the better King
if possible in the endgame after 95 as
mentioned the ambulance key played King
a form which is a little tactical trick
Knight f6 was played and King back yeah
the the little point is that of course
now black cannot take here because these
7 is quite embarrassing it's not
necessary however black can simply take
the pawn on d6 and now we see that now
of course the bishop is hanging it has
to move and now King c5 note that this
is just much much more precise than the
than the immediate capture if we compare
this to the position that we had earlier
when I was showing the this thing here
white was much more active he would get
the pawn back and this is far less far
less clear in the game in the game
position the whole situation was was
very very clear after this and like
captured to put it on the board again
here black was a tool to control the
king is more active you have to spawn
and still you prevent all kinds of
activity from White's King yeah white
now still try to move aged form a g4
check King D to King D form
at this point here yeah Malinsky
resigned yeah it is now relatively
simple because you have two extra pawns
and I'm sorry two passports two
passports and it's pretty simple you
just put put the H bone up the board and
white White's King and Bishop they
they're not able to defend against both
pawns maybe we can just put some more
moves on the board in case you're
wondering how it is exactly happening
let's say white plays Bishop f3 yeah
that's the most logical square probably
then h5 and because blacks total control
yeah white really cannot do much you can
can mostly shuffle yeah something like
that and then we just push the pawn and
around this time the problem is that
black is having this kind of ideas like
Knight F 2 and H 1 Queen and if white
now tries to defend against that we have
the second point running so this is a
very simple technical task you just push
both pawns and whites pieces are
overloaded they cannot defend against
both passed pawns that are so so far
apart this is a very important thing C
and H pawn are so far apart that you
really cannot coordinate both both white
pieces in defense so what to take from
this example in a closed position where
a passed pawn can easily be located like
here when black managed to find the best
possible setup in this kind of position
the bishop is not a very effective piece
the night as the great locator here only
six is just much better note that in
this position here a sort of
non-dogmatic pawn push was guaranteeing
the progress always think concretely in
those positions if there is a something
concrete possible like b5 here then it
should be done even if it looks slightly
logical and
to open up the position for the bishop
it is a good way to proceed because you
hear by concrete calculation can
determine that after c-4 you will have
excellent chances to win all the pawns
and exactly that was happening him one
point on the second point was now gone
on the D file and note this precision
they had the precise move order here and
capturing the pawn was very important it
was much better to play this move and
prevent the White King from marching up
then to grab the pawn immediately very
important also is to to note the the
best possible piece configuration that
Kasparov was aiming for from the
beginning route d6 to a six rook d6 to a
six to a for attacking the weakness and
the night over to d6 this is very
important that you think of of schemes
and setups in those kind of slow
positions where you can really maneuver
it's simply the best possible approach
to just look for the best possible
places for your pieces and and then
check what's the best move on to to
actually get them to to those squares so
it's a step by step process and at the
end we'll always come to some concrete
calculation to find out the best way
forward from the position where you have
improved your pieces zone to the utmost
yeah I hope you enjoyed this example of
a good end gameplay it shows a number of
very instructive points thanks for
watching